the morning after
the remnants of what's taken place here
this is the area outside iraq's
parliament building
now home to demonstrators for the
foreseeable future
they come and go under the watchful eye
of security personnel belonging to the
man they follow
shia leader mother al-sadr
[Applause]
known as sotherists they're fed up with
the political system they have come from
all over the country
27 year old ali arrived in baghdad on
wednesday
and took part in the first storming of
this building
we promised
to stay here as long as it takes we
reject the government and want the
corrupt politicians to be punished
including former prime minister nuria
maliki we are waiting for orders from
our leader
whose leadership represents reform
is a cleric from najaf he's also been in
the capital since wednesday
he teaches in one of the seminaries in
the holy city belonging to the souther
family
and says he's helping mukhtar al-sadr
fulfill his wish for a better iraq
this is what we want a united iraqi
government we want to achieve one solid
iraqi government we don't need anything
other than that we're staying here
because of demands that were presented
by the representative of the iraqi
people syed muktara al-sadr
these protesters are making themselves
comfortable worried if they leave mps
could hold an unannounced session to
approve the candidate nominated by an
iran-backed group mohammed shaya
al-sudani
this is the iraqi constitution it was
crafted by the americans in 2003 and it
officially became the rule of law in
2005. it is one of the main reasons
these demonstrators are here today and
until this document is amended and
fundamental reforms are implemented they
say scenes like this will continue
dorsal jabari al-jazeera baghdad
welfare is the director of the center
for the study of the middle east at
indiana university and a former iraqi
ambassador to the year and he joins us
from london uh thanks very much for
being on the program so just how
dangerous a situation is this now do you
think
it's a very dangerous situation because
the
political
system in iraq and the political parties
are an absolute deadlock and have been
since elections were held in october 10
months ago
um this
there's a history of these kinds of acts
by
frustrated iraqis taking over this or
that government building
very little good has ever come from this
kind of conduct
but it has the potential of spiraling
out of control
and unfortunately too many in the iraqi
political class it seems to me are
prepared for
engaging in violence including mokhtar
and indeed
this is not violence in the sense of
directing
violence at individuals but it is an
assault on the institutions in iraq
however flawed they are to take over
a parliament building and to prevent
parliament from meeting no matter how
much you disagree with their
what they may
seek to do it sounds very trumpian uh if
i may say so given what you say then to
what extent is wider public opinion on
their side or not
i i judge i mean i don't think anyone's
done polling but uh judging by at least
social media this is a very popular
thing that they're doing however wrong i
think it is in what in the specific acts
of taking over parliament i agree with
the goal of the protesters and have
since 2019
but i suspect that a lot of iraqis are
thoroughly fed up with the political
class uh in baghdad um and i
suspect uh that they are they have wide
support but this is simply not a formula
for going forward much of the suther's
representatives may say he's a
representative of iraq but the truth of
the matter is out of 329
seats he only won 73 of them so
why is he the representative of iraq who
can impose his will or rather prevent
parliament from carrying out its
constitutional function
faisal israeli will leave it there thank
you very much indeed for your insights
today
thank you